Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now for the first time in awhile I'm going to be starting off the episode directly by commemorating the people who commented in the last video,
and the first one up is Diego Mapillllll,
who said "When will he meet the Ghost Leviathan, in the Lost River?"
Which I don't know if the Ghost Leviathan is there yet, but I'm officially in the experimental build once again
and even though Big Box Barry is a little damaged, ignore that everything's fine, I'm not worried about it.
Next up is Alex H, who said, "Is it me or does anyone else count how many seconds before Mark freaks out after saying,
'Okay everything seems to be fine.' "
And HEY... That's not my fault that the WORLD!... decides to fuck me over as soon as I say those words
as if that's alien code to come attack me.
Not my fault.
Then there's Carson Blnd who said,
"Silent mode doesn't work if you keep screaming,
'Stop attacking me!' "
and, uh- that made me realize that uh- probably from the outside all the fish are hearing
this muffled "OHGOD! OHGODPLEASE! NO!....."
Like coming from this weird giant yellow boat that's just trying to sneak along at a snail's pace.
So entirely, that's all my fault
and I'm sorry about that.
But, now that we're back in the experimental build, there's
something very very special waiting for
us down in the depths back in the Lost River.
Or not even in the Lost River.
The Active Lava Zone, which I am eventually
going back down to. But before I do that-
before I do that, I have to; Number One, go
to the island at full speed, and then I
have to get Marble Melons which I should've
had this whole time I don't know why?
I've been choking down 1700 of these
Goddamn Lantern Fruit, when I could have
just been eating Marble Melons this whole time
and I would have been totally fine
and then I would have more than one
planter and I wouldn't have just been
eating until my stomach explodes and my
guts just froth out of my belly all over
my inside of my Big Box Barry! If that
sentence made sense in any other world,
in any other context, I'd be amazed. But
that is the truth of my situation, so I'm
gonna go real quick to the island. I'm
gonna grab that stuff and I'mma be right back-
I'm gonna - I'mma bout to beach
myself aren't I?
Ohhhhhh Nelly!
and then, I'm going to cycle back
because there's only one other upgrade
that I want to make for my Big Box Barry
and that is the Sonar Upgrade and to do
that I need Polyaniline.
And to make Polyaniline I need
Hydrochloric Acid. And to do that I need
to go get some Deep Mushrooms because
you can only make hydrochloric acid out
of certain acid mushrooms not these guys,
you gotta get the Deep Shrooms. You have
to have them for that. I didn't even know
about Hydrochloric Acid. I didn't even
know what Polyanaline was!
I don't even think I've ever made
that, but now I will. So I'm gonna be
right back as soon as I find me a Marble Melon.
Oh that is... Tha-that's... That's...
That's weird.
Why are you guys just floating on the
surface like that?
I'm a little- I'm more
than a little bit perturbed by that.
Usually they're moving or they're like
breaching or- or something or other, but
they're just- oh my God it's a bigger pod
than I thought it was gonna be. Okay alright
you carry on, I gotta get to the
island... oh that is majestic. I know I
gotta eat that's why I'm going to get
a marble melon. Are you bothered? *miurgh* hehe
I'm seducing them with my massive 'miurghs'.
uh-oh. uh-oh. Why do we have those sharks around
here? That's- they're- they're not supposed-
they're about to get rammed that's what
they're about to get- and what the hell is
that in the- I don't know what's going on
but these assholes are gonna get rammed- 'hey oh
oh no I'm so soOOrry!...'
oh-ho-ho-ho-ho, fuck you dude.
Oh man, that hurt more me more than it hurt them.
Ah shit! Can't catch me. Shubooski
Not when I sla-  not when I- Oh my God
Fire detected?! Oh shit! That's not what I meant!
That's not what I wanted!
I didn't want that! Oh I didn't want that. Okay.
Where are we going?
Where's the fire? Where's the fire? I hear a fire.
Can I get down to the lower deck please?
Hop hop hop. OHGOD HAAA SPLOOSH
OH GOODOOSHK! OHHH Goodooshky! Oh goodooshky!
Okay, what else we got?
*Epic Dubstep*
Fuckin cue the dubstep!
Hahahah
*Snaps back to reality*
Fuck, uh oh, what the Hell is that?
Alrighty then, well we- we got our first fire
and we're- we're not doing good. Okay,
note to self; body slamming the local
fauna is not a good idea and not a good
preventative for damage. Oh my God, okay.
Oh no. Oh, that's my laser. I don't need that.
I need the... where's- where's my-
where's my repair tool?!..
Did- did I drop it?!
What in the shit holes?!..
What in the shit my dicks?!
And- yeah I'm aware of that, thank
you. But what happened to my goddamn
doodleledanger? What happened to- oh what?
What happened to my repair tool? What is Cave
Sulphur?! I don't know what Cave Sulphur is!
I'm going to be very pissed. Thank
The Lord!
I almost shat my britches there. Okay, alright then. Let me put my fire
extinguisher back too because I
have a funny feeling I'm gonna need it
again soon okay. Fuck, alright good.
Hopefully that refills. Alright let me
go repair. Sorry about this. A little bit
of a crisis always seems to get in my way,
when you bodyslam the opposition.
Y'know I'd like to think that body slams are the
solution to all of life's problems.
Got an angry neighbor? just body slam them into submission.
Dog misbehaving? just
bodyslam that bitch.
Grandma acting up? Just bodyslam her! You
never know. Huuuhh.. I should shut up Alright I think that's
most of it if not all of it. Alright.
So now we're back on track.
Thank you, oh we got some damage up there,
I'll get that when I get over to the
place. Oh no, it's about to be dark. Maybe
I should actually use this bed that I
built for such a person that I need to do that.
Oooh it's so pretty!
I sometimes forget how beautiful that is
over there. God that's a gorgeous sunset.
that's something to be commemorated by
me screaming at the top of my lungs
about how terrifying everything is *intense inhaling* ah nah not now.
Ah he he he he! Ah ha ha! Ha ha haaa ha ha ha!
Where is my Goddamn knife? Hang on I gotta
get this. Hey you want to go bruh?
You want to go? I've sliced up worse than
you in my day.
Are you dead now? Are you dead? Who's
skittering out there? Grab these bad boys-
Hey- Oh you're dead.
Alright, I got the Marble Melons! I got the
Meloones. I got 'em. I could have at any
time come back and got these but then I
didn't
cause I'm dumb. So I'll be right back ,once I
plant these bad boys inside my boat.
Hopefully I can plant these bad boys
inside my boat. I think I can, therefore I will.
OoOohhh boosky! Okay, and then put
these bad boys, boink, and then, boink, and then
I want that small- I want- I want big
meaty marble melons, yeah.. Hell yeah, and
I don't know why.. I don't know why
there's Chinese potatoes on here but I'm
gonna, munch, and munch. Yes! Yes! I've got
Meloones, hell yeah! Finally! Why has it
taken me so long to do this? I'm just a
big dumb goof. But I'm gonna need more uhh-
more pots eventually for all of the
melone because the Lantern Fruit,
that'll make a lot of stuff in a small area, but
for the meloone
Imma need waay more. So what I'm gonna do is,
I'm going to make individual small
plants then I'm gonna have the marble
melons all lining the walls in here
because I. Am. A. Bad. Ass.
blooong, boink! Okay, so
I'm gonna have Marble Meloones over there,
and that'll be better for me. Heh
yeah, reclaimed water. Fuck yeah. Try for a-
a swig of victory piss. Hell yeah! Okay, so
now that we got that out of the way that
was a minor objective on this whole
endeavor. Now comes the real heart of the
matter: getting this Sonar Upgrade which
is something that I'm very keen on
getting. So what I got to do is, I got a
dive3x down into the deep depths
of the ocean. Hopefully not too loudly
but I'm gonna go loudly anyway because
I'm a badass and I don't care, I got mah
shield. And so long as I got my shield I
think I'll be okay, which is a goddamn
lie tell myself to go to sleep at night.
But down there deep in the depths down
here somewhere is the Deep Shrooms. Not
in this area, not necessarily in this
area but, in the areas below this- Hi
Warpywoo.
Hey how's it going Warpstache? Not in my areas over
there but down here in the Sea Treader's
path. I think it's the closest place
to be able to get Deep Shrooms.
I could also go down into the Lost River
and there would be tons of 'em down there
and uh- I probably could do that but I'm-
I don't- I don't want to do that that's the key.
I don't want to go there. So I'll be
right back once I get to those Deep Shrooms.
Here it is. hi!
Oh you freakish bastards. Oh you freaky
weirdos.
Alright don't mind me. Hey!... What's up?
How's it doing? Okay I'm just gonna go
into your tunnel here. This seems to be
the place I mean the choir is screaming;
"Ah! it's Markiplier, not him again."
but uh- alas yes it is me, unfortunately
here to ruin everything.
Oh hi Sea Treaders. God I've never
actually ridden the entirety of the Sea
Treader's path, so I didn't actually know
the scope of it like- it's legit huge. Like
geez.. Ah it's so crazy. Alright, but I think
in here, and I am now going in the cave.
I am in the cave now. Yes! That's what I'm
looking for right down there, the Deep
Shrooooms.
So, I'm gonna go out and get them, but
some- something to warn you guys about
these Deep Shrooms.
Apparently, harvesting them is tricky
because they can damage you. I mean they
are very, very potent acid. At least
that's what I've been told. So I'm gonna
collect what I can in whatever way I
can.
Shcoopdee..
Huh...
*stab*
Ah! That's what it did!
Oh! Owie! Ah, but that's how you get Deep
Shroom spore. That's interesting. So if you
slice 'em you, get Deep Shroom
spore. Ah, but it hurts like a
son-of-a-bitch because you just spill
acid all over your body. So anyway, I'm
going to pick up a bunch of these things
because I need to mix them with a very
special element - Gold! And when you mix
them with gold you create Polyaniline.
So I'm hoping- oh God you are- you are weird
creatures for being so docile. Oh I don't
like it. Okay, alright. Man it feels like
forever since the first time I saw those
things and they were just weird horrifying
elephant creatures just treading the
bottom of the ocean here. Real real prime
subject of something I never want to
meet. Even though they're they're like
totally harmless but- I mean not totally
harmless. Nothing here is totally harmless.
But there we go: Hydrochloric Acid
Oh, needed salt?
is that what I needed? ah, but I can make
Polyaniline now. Now I believe I need two
of these if I'm not mistaken. I am gonna
need two of these, so I need to make-
I need to get another salt deposit and I
then I need to slap another one of these bad
boys together in the here, and then, once
I have a second Polyaniline, I forget
what the other subject material that I
needed, but I don't think it's too
terribly complicated because if I go up
here to the other crafting bay, which,
technically speaking,
is just a simple thing. I need Magnetite.
And I believe, I believe I did gather up
a bunch of Magnetite in a previous
episode. I think I did?
That's Aluminum Oxide, Uraninite uuh
did I get Magnetite? did I? Uuuh I don't know..
*intense inhaling*
Ah I don't even know what Magnetite looks
like anymore. There's Kyanite.
ahhhh shooty-tooties!
Flooty booties! Ah titty widdies. Okay.
Can't believe that Eye-eye is still alive in there.
Let me take this out of here cause this is not supposed  to be there.
Very looow chance.
Very low chance.
*insert tension*
Magnetite!
I did! I have exactly THREE! I have exactly
THREEEE!
Okay, and then when you put the Magnetite-
Ohh shit dude! Well, Goddamn it I now have
-Lemme save to make sure this doesn't crash or nothing-
but I now have, the lovely; Sonar Upgrade.
Blapity Bloopity, and there you Goopty.
So now if I go over here to the main
area right here, and I hit good old Sonar..
Oh.. Oh! That's so nice!
*Amaized....*
That is so nice!
And this is like the perfect place for it!
Because I can actually see where the
flip frickin frackin I'm going! Oh my God.
And I know that probably takes a good
bit of power but, you don't understand,
how helpful that is!
Because I fly blind
a lot of the time when I'm in this big
ass Big Box Barry, I fly blind - does this
affect creatures? Does it? Man
Booong!
Nah, unfortunately it don't hit
creatures but that's fine. Oh but that is
so cool. Oh you guys, I am- oh that's so
cool! I can SEE!
I can flip dicking see now!
And it doesn't take that much power!
So I got that! I got the shield.
I am freaking good to go!
I am G to G!
Oh man this is so cool!
Oh ring the bell, bing bonger. It's like that
SCP Bell; Bing bong bring it on ya
bunch of douchers! So now, the reason I
wanted this is because it's going to
maaake- navigating deep down in the depths
that much easier for me. And because of
that I'm able to navigate tighter spaces,
see where I need to go, see caves when I
need to see caves, which isn't always the
case, caves like to hide on me. They do,
they definitely do. But now, the last step
is to go down into the deep and get down
to that lava zone. In between now and the
next episode I'm going to do some farming.
But, I am fully prepared to go
down there and build my base, right at
the heart of that castle and hopefully
not die to the Sea Dragon. I've got a
weird idea that uh- if I get enough of
those "thorn shooters" maybe I could use
them as like defensive turrets against
the uh- Sea Dragon, but I don't think it's
going to be nearly enough for what I
have in mind. So, with that being said,
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
Look forward to going down into the deep,
in the next episode. So thanks again, let
me know how I'm doing in the comments below
and if you comment well I might
just put you on a locker. so thanks
again and as always, I will see you, in
the next video.
Buh-bye!